o da una vita e mezza che non lo faccio
che lo giuro non notare lo faccio per me
se mi sento quasi in dovere di farlo
come se ne mancassero per chi non la
conoscesse questo sito che ti mette due
opzioni e più devi scegliere quale delle
due faresti preferiresti starnutire ogni
tre minuti o avere sempre la sensazione
di starnutire non farlo mai
in questo caso non ho veramente la prima
veramente difficile non siamo ai partiti
con una così difficile direi avere
sempre la sensazione di starnutire
perché a questo punto ha una certa penso
di abituarmi quindi la seconda bene
lecca il burro di arachidi dal piede di
un bobo cos'è un novo un omosessuale o
perdere 250 dollari nel mercato
azionario dipende come un hobby
ma esterni per 250 euro volentieri
preferiresti vedere sfocato tutto il
tempo vedere tutto in bianco e nero mica
prodotto così no vabbè ovviamente in
bianco e nero almeno vedi e cioè sfogato
non vedi niente
preferiresti mangia il tuo peso in piedi
di maiale non ho capito pure immergiti
in una pozza di rafano e vermi non ho
capito il mio peso in piedi di maiale
dovrei mangiare i piedi di maiale piede
di porco ma facciamo emergency alla fine
fare suv non è mai così male
preferiresti uccidere il drago salvare
la principessa ma una domanda per
deficienti c'è mio dio il drago dopo che
l'hai ucciso chiavi primo e secondo
almeno questi 47 per cento secondo me è
pietro preferiresti non avere i pollici
o avere solo pollici non meno invece va
neanche una mano con solo pollicino a
non avere i pollici preferiresti dati
qualcuno ha detto sarebbe uscire uscire
con qualcuno che sembra sempre un
dodicenne che riusciva sempre con haga
12 anni o uscire con una che sembra
sempre che ne abbia 80 sento già freddo
ai polsi dopo questa domanda non lo so
raga ma che domande ma scusate ma chi è
che fa se domani non lo so oggi oh mio
dio a pratiche dodicenni di adesso
sembrano perché l'abbiamo 25 prova beh
forse quella di 80 così a spaccio per
mia nonna 12 watt ora che c'è ora a
unanime la risposta ecco questo quando
una ragazza esce con me la stessa cosa
io dimostro sempre dieci anni in meno
perché ne ho 22 ma ne dimostro 12 e
quindi adesso capisco che cosa prova
preferirsi e se in grado di correre 40
miglia all'ora o possedere una macchina
considerando il fatto che la patente non
ce l'ho manco per il bene corriamo
veloci preferiresti mangiare un piatto
pieno di kakà o mangiare un piede umano
ma io farei una roba prendere il piede
non superi nella cacca omar mix
certo che dovete avere proprio una vita
brutta perché avesse cosa il piede
preferiresti diventare il tuo
personaggio dei videogiochi preferito o
si il tuo film preferito cioè proprio mi
trasformo in un cofanetto con tanto di
dvd e blu ray un cofanetto non è
ma se quindi preferisce avere un extra
estrema narcolessia può avere un brutto
caso di tourette ma i suoi tic
peggiorano
sembra che abbia perso la testa in
genere a una disfunzione di questa
particolare area cerebrale e ritorno
della sindrome ragazzi al ritorno e
ritorno e ritorno
comunque la narcolessia quando ti
addormenti io soffro comunque di
narcolessia prescinde quindi ciò tutte e
due già tutte e due feriti essere
mangiato da un leone ho mangiato dalle
formiche e secondo me sarebbe
imbarazzante essere mangiato da delle
formiche non so perché non può quando
vai in paradiso poi se sei stato bravo
poi non è che poi dirà come sei morto
due io sono morto perché mi hanno
mangiato delle formiche brucia sabu di
da sé ma che schifo che fai magna magna
da un leone si rivolti un sacco in
paradiso però ne leone leone cane fifone
tra l'altro preferiresti essere
costretto a guardare la tv tutto il
tempo non guardare ha fatto la tv io la
tv non la guardo mai nell'universo
quindi assolutamente non guardare mai
dati ormai se guardo la tv è solo per
guardare
netflix preferiresti bere 5 once di
vodka dal naso nel mentre cantare l'inno
russo ovvero il 5 oggi di salsa piccante
dal naso 5 pollici once upon a time e
direi once di salsa piccante
preferiresti assolutamente puzza di
ascelle per il resto della tua vita
oppure perdere completamente il tuo
senso dell'olfatto bene io non posso
perché non c'è ormoni addosso preferirei
perdere il senso dell'olfatto perché
almeno non sento gli altri che puzzano
questo è un problema come davvero
fastidio quando la gente puzzano quindi
preferiresti morire in un apocalisse
zombie in una guerra nucleare
direi e morire un'apocalisse zombie da
almeno mica ti diverti un po col fucile
prima di morire completamente preferirsi
indossare sempre le crocs o le calze i
sandali no dai ti prego odio sia i crabs
che le calze i sandali non lo so madama
che le crocs preferiresti incontrare pd
fi o incontrare banos aiuti pie
si provi camera che puoi starci 1
raccontare quanta gente in disaccordo
quanta gente accordi melo subito nota
chi è
dovresti essere cieco essere stupido
sono da stupido quindi non voglio essere
anche ceco preferiresti avere una vera
spada laser o salvare un ragazzo
africano a caso dalla fame
ma cosa c'entrano una con l'altra si è
fatto tutto lo spiego nemiche facendo 11
su star wars e su un ragazzo africano
che ha fame cosa il ragazzo africano
anche perché a me star wars non è che
cioè mi piace si è bello però non sono
fan da dire wow incredibile preferirsi
scoprire quando finisce il mondo come
finisce il mondo e minchia dai direi
quando perché dal quando riesci più o
meno capire come finisce
tanto stupido esce domani che cazzo ne
avrei che se tu fossi mangiato vivo
sempre allegre le domande mi fa piacere
preferiresti per prima cosa ingerire la
testa o si prima inghiottito inghiottito
tipo eren dai che poi alla fine diventa
un gigante riesco dallo stomaco e
spoiler ho fatto ma mani preferiresti
combattere 100 alunni di terza
elementare uno alla volta o 50 alunni di
terza elementare allo stesso tempo ma
che domande sono perché combattere
concerto di the r's alimentaristi haters
non lo so dio mio qualche domanda non ho
mai pensato di menar bambini di terza
elementare dio santo che poi magari
questa domanda a quale legge un bambino
di terza elementare che cosa risponde
torino è finito a prescindere cento una
volta preferiresti tieni il sangue sul
piatto da un bumper dei preferiti che un
bambino ti succhia il sangue vela sto
traducendo in italiano leggibile o che
uno zombie noah già se il tuo cervello
tra le due cose e io direi mi sa che il
bambino che succhia sangue perché non
vorrei dire una stronzata ma secondo me
quando uno ti succhia via sangue poi una
certa non senti più niente perché non
c'è il sangue quindi in teoria il
vampiro infatti tutti hanno scelto
vampiro solo che non sto qua ad
aspettare che questo arrivi a 88 per
cento preferisce ascoltare tutto tranne
il tuo musicista artista preferito
ascoltare solo il musicista artista
preferito di ascolto solo martin garics
quindi va bene così
o preferiresti essere ucciso da jason di
venerdì 13 o da ghost face di screening
c'è jason perché il ciccio gamer
preferiresti fi respirare il ghiaccio
ceva bel respiro di ghiaccio o avere
l'alito di fuoco sì come limoni male se
è la rito di fuoco preferiresti essere
cieco con incredibili abilità musicali o
sorda con capacità artistiche
straordinarie
la prima perché me lo faccio il duetto
con sheeran preferirsi visitare hogwarts
visitare narnia equa penso che tutti mi
darebbero automaticamente la risposta
hogwarts perché mi conoscete però in
realtà non è così
forse no dani è bella ci vorrà che 9
potter ed che invece troppo prevedesse
essere maschio femmina è questa è
difficile sai che vuol dire potersi
guardare le bocce ogni volta che vuoi
non lo so no dovrei partorire maschio
poi non ho le mie cose volete mettere io
già solo quando la febbre sembra morto
quel ciclo mimì mi faccio prima a
impiccarmi preferireste essere nudo di
fronte a tutta la tua famiglia per tre
ore ho il cuore venuto per il centro
versi prevenuti in piazza del duomo
l'unico che corre che vedo la mia
famiglia uno perché avremo un sacco
fastidio si vabbè però c'è il centro
mica ti vedono tutti poi mica io tra
l'altro mi fanno le foto vabbè un casino
nudo altre ore nella mia famiglia poi
mica è nata la mia famiglia mi fa le
foto miss pace ovunque preferiresti si
era attaccato da 50 cavalli grossi come
un'anatra può essere attaccato da un
anatra grossa con un cavallo da ray dei
calci di continuo quindi la prima un
calcio dice proprio il fuori campo
continuamente preferiresti essere una
sirena una principessa dipende c'è
non lo so ma dio mio una principessa sai
quanta gente che il gioco cioè i miei
pony tutti tutti i miei sono i pony ciò
il garzone ciò che pietro tra l'altro
vedessi giocare a minecraft della vita
reale o giocare a mario kart e della
vita reale a mario kart nella vita reale
ci ho già giocato perché facciamo i go
kart e lanciavamo le cose però non lo
potevo forse non potevo dirvelo questo
che avere uno spoiler
vabbè non ha detto ogni voi non avete
sentito niente non avete sentito secondo
me minecraft perché normalmente puoi
giocare a mario kart nella vita reale
sentimenti d'accordo voglio dire quindi
minecraft preferirei avere una macchina
incredibilmente bella o posso dire un
elicottero personale
vasto mare anche voi siete scemi
quanta gente ha scelto la macchina c'è
un elicottero fra ma tu stai scherzando
a voi siete malati di mente la trieste
essere un calciatore di livello mondiale
un giocatore di cricket di livello
mondiale ma chi sono gag al cricket ma
che è insomma come si gioca a cricket
venier cricket mano il calcio a mazzi
mazza scherzo da ragazzi o gruppo
episodio tra la un botto che non facevo
lo faresti perché ogni tanto mi mi
dimentico che esiste poi mi sveglio di
quanto lo faresti dai facciamo un
episodio però io vi sia piaciuto ragazzi
con cui lo fa come se bisogna inventare
mi piace anche a questi gli scheletri e
noi ci vediamo l'anno prossimo vinto dai
ragazzi
[Musica]